et bien c'est le mec de la télé
d'ailleurs junior est ce que tu te
rappelles tu as première télé 187 france
3 qui était à l'arrêt la tête et folle
chemise à rayures noires et blanches
beau délire et julien courbet pour le
hit parade
julien courbet qui ne vous parle pas des
points de la jambe et demie par année de
son grand concours qui passionne toute
l'aquitaine c'est très simple dit titre
vous en sélectionner trois une carte
postale fun boîtes postales 70 33000
0,30 bordeaux cedex nous tirerons au
sort et plein de cadeaux à gagner le
vainqueur du jour s'appelle hervé cholet
il habite au haillan il nous envoyait
une superbe carte postale représentant
la mairie et l'église et il gagne 10
maxi 45 tours une cassette un 33 tours
et une place pour aller voir frankyg à
hollywood il y aura d'autres places de
concerts à gagner dans la prochaine
émission
[Applaudissements]
très rapidement j'ai démarré sur france3
d'autres choses et c'est s'étaient tous
les quinze jours et c est un jour on
m'appelle on me dit voilà on s'est
planté dans l'organisation des émissions
il faut que tu nous fasses tous les
jours une émission de 10 minutes et tu
démarres lundi prochain on était mardi
mais je dis je fais quoi avec quel
budget zéro budget tu te démerdes donc
je prends deux tables et j'organise un
jour on pose des questions et c'est tout
il n'y avait rien d'autre n'est pas de
jingle de machin y avait pas un sou sauf
que comme on est mardi et qu'il faut du
monde le lundi que ça pas une grosse
audience il n'y a pas de candidat doit
obliger de faire venir premier match ma
mère contre le frère deuxième match mon
frère qui avait gagné contre mon
colocataire est comme ça pendant deux
jours c'est la famille qui a joué
jusqu'à ce que répète away incroyable et
je n'ai aucun qui m'appelait julien
puisqu'à l'époque j'ai appelé frédéric
par le succès du midi julien dont là et
vous avez donné une bonne réponse oh
merci frédéric nom julien mois que j'ai
pris ma man et tout ce que vous appeliez
frédéric ouvret sa vie en attachant des
bonnes excuses et frédéric courbe est à
la base un il avait changé parce qu'ils
avaient des liens julien via un frère et
un v6 est donc vous avez fait cette
émission avec votre famille pendant
pendant dernier quelques jours et bat
lui et lui il a fait 20 ans de carrière
tous les quatre ont fait à toris et sa
famille se sont faites alors qu'il a le
même ton le même temps est la même il
n'ya pas chasser la même période
c'est pas juste à côté des fameux coup
de fil de quatre meilleures et où voulez
vous embrouiller pourra robinet en fuite
[Musique]
oui julien courbet on n'a pas plus parlé
tout à l'heure
est-ce que ce n'était pas un peu
beaucoup s'il vous plaît à un moment
donné je vous dirai stop ça voudra dire
que j'ai fini ma phrase vous pourrez
parler à ce moment là qui a trois
figures de ses spectateurs qui menton
derrière je passais le mobile
exc